فعلا المدير العام لمنظمه الصحه العالميه
رصد المتحول ام الكرون في 25 دوله
حيث قال المركز الصيني لمكافحه الامراض
والوقايه منها لو سجل خمس وفيات جديده
بفيروس كورونا بعد القلق الذي اعلنت عنه
المنظمه العالميه بسبب تزايد عدد الاصابات
بالفيروس في الصين
قد اكدت امكانيه سيطره بلادها على الوضع
الحالي مع تعديل سياسه الوقايه من الوباء
والسيطره عليه في الصين
ما هو احساسه وانت تقراين مره ثانيه
اخباركم
[ضحك]
متقدمه
المسؤولون الامريكيون اقترحوا طرقا غير
مباشره لتقديم اللقاحات محاوله لاستيعاب
الحساسيه السياسيه في الصين بشان قبول
المساعده الخارجي
وبلجيكا والسويد واليونان انها ستلزموا
المسافرين القادمين من الصين باجراء
اختبار كوفيت 19 وذلك عقب اجتماعا لخبراء
الصحه في بروكسل القرار جاء بعد ان اتخذت
بريطانيا وفرنسا وايطاليا وكوريا الجنوبيه
والولايات المتحده قرارا بفرد اجراء
اضافيه على القادمين من الصين
من القاهره
لمنظمه الصحه العالميه للشرق المتوسط
الدكتور احمد المنذر دكتور احمد اهلا بك
كيف ترصد المنظمه هذا الارتفاع المضطرد في
حالات الاصابه بكرونا
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]
تقريبا في اخر 28 يوم من العام 2020 همم
الممتاز من خمسه ديسمبر الى واحد يناير
هذا العام تم الابلاغ عن اكثر من حوالي عن
اكثر من 14 ونصف مليون حاله اصابه على
مستوى العالم واكثر من 46,000 حاله وفاه
جديده بن زياده تقريبا نوعا ما ممكن القول
عنها 25% في عدد الاصابات 21% في عدد
الوفيات على التوالي مقارنه ب 28 يوم او
الشهر الذي سبقهم يعني في شهر نوفمبر الى
بدايه ديسمبر ولكن ولله الحمد يعني على
الرغم من الزيادات التي يعني لوحظت في في
الصين على سبيل المثال على مستوى وتم
الابلاغ عن انخفاض في عدد الاصابات وعدد
الوفيات مقارنه بالاسبوع الذي سبقه ايه
يعني وهو الاسبوع الممتد من 26 ديسمبر الى
واحد يناير
بنسبه 22% في الاصابات انخفاض و12% انخفاض
في عدد الوفيات
وبشكل عام يعني اعتبارا من واحد يناير او
حتى واحد يناير 20 23 هذا العام بلغ عدد
الاصابات في العالم اجمع 656 مليون اصابه
مؤكده واكثر من 66 من 10 مليون حاله وفاه
على مستوى الاقليم حتى تاريخ 4 يناير بلغ
عدد الاصابات حوالي 23 مليون و200,000
حاله يصابه مؤكده وعدد الوفيات تقريبا
350,000 حاله وفاه مؤكده في الاقليم
فهذه هي باللغه العربيه طيب لمترجم لغه
الارقام وباختصار كما كنت قبل قليل يتحدث
انا وزين عندما اسلم على هذه الاقامه
وعوده المتحور
بشار اشعر بالقلق قلق مثلي مثل اي مواطن
اختبر هذه الجائحه في اعلى مستوى العالم
هل يجب ان نطمئن من من خلال هذه الارقام
مقارنه بذروه الجارحه التي شاهدناها
هو طبعا هناك مؤشرات يعني تبعث همم على
القلق ان صح التعبير ومؤشرات اخرى تجعلنا
نطمئن اذا الدول والافراد والمجتمعات
اتبعت النائب الذي اتبعناه سابقا فعلى
سبيل المثال هناك كان في انخفاض في همم
يعني وتيره التطعيم
للمختلف في الافراد في مختلف المجتمعات
والجوال فهذا يعني شيء نوعا ما مقلق فلذلك
على الدول ان ترجع الى وتيره التطعيم من
هذا الامراض هناك يعني مؤشر اخر وهو يعني
نوعا ما تراه في الافراد والمجتمعات
والدول في تطبيق الاجراءات الاحترازيه
والوقائيه المعروفه البعد عن الاماكن
المستحمه لبس الكمامات نظافه اليدين كما
هي ساعدتنا خلال يعني وسط يجب علينا
الالتزام بها حاليا في الجانب الاخر بوادر
تبعث على الاطمئنان هو انه كما ذكرت يعني
همم الدول ولا افراد ولا امام الصحيه
تعلمت الكثير من والعبر خلال السنتين
والنفس والنصف المصر كلمتين فلذلك يعني لا
يوجد نقص في الخضره ولا يوجد نقص في
المعرفه والعلم علينا ان نرجع الى ابجديات
التعامل مع مثل هذه الجوارح كما وسط
المنظمه سابقا وهو همم الحكومه باسرها
والحكومه مجتمعه والمجتمع باسله والتكامل
فيما بينهم وانا على يقين باذن الله بمعنى
هذا المناهج سوف نتمكن من تخطي هذه العقبه
الدكتور يعني لا يبدو ان هناك استعدادا لا
لدى الشعوب ولا لدى الافراد ولا لدى
الحكومات للعوده الى هذه الاجراءات
القاسيه همم مره اخرى
ولعلهم يتشجعون من طبيعه المتحورات
الموجوده حاليا لانها غير خطيره همم يعني
تبدو خطورتها في الصين اكثر من غيرها لانه
الصين لم تطعم بشكل كامل
وبانها تبنت سياسه صفر التي عانت همم
بالاحرى انه لم يصب الناس بالمتحورات
الماضيه وبالتالي هم يختبرونه لاول مره هل
هذا الاحساس بالتراخي في محله
يعني هو طبعا لتصحيح يا اخي زين العابدين
هو القصد بالاجراءات الوقائيه ليس القصد
منها يعني غلق الحدود واغلاق المطارات
وتقييد السفر والحركه لا قصد هو اتباع
الاجراءات الوقائيه المعروفه كما ذكرتها
يعني
رصد وعمل يعني تقسي للمصابين والمخالطين
بشكل دقيق جدا ومشاركه البيانات انا اتفق
معك انه هناك نوع من نوعا ما قلق بين
الافران والشعوب فيما يخص هذه الطفرات
التي حصلت ولكن على سبيل المثال هذه
الطفره الحاليه التي نتكلم عنها وهي اكس
بي بي او اكس بي بي 1.5 كما يطلق عليها هي
نابعه من همم اندماج طفارات دينيه لسلالات
سابقه همم تتميز على حسب الدراسات الحاليه
والبيانات المتوفره الانتشار ولكن في نفس
الوقت لما نتكلم عن شده
ومخامه المرض
هي نوع الماء اقل حده من متحور دلتا ونوعا
ما يعني مشابهه للمتحول اومكرون واخف نوعا
في الشده ولكن
يتميز هذا المتحوله وهذه الطفره بمقدرتها
على التغلب
مناعه الجسم الناتجه عن التطعيم او
الناتجه عن اصابات سابقه وهذا هو المبعث
انطلق لدينا على ذكر التطعيمات معظمنا اخذ
ثلاث جرعات وهنا كمان همم اخذ الرابعه كما
يحدث الولايات المتحده هل هناك اي امكانيه
للعوده للحديث عن التطعيمات مره اخرى
والله هو الحديث وارد يا اختي مياده يعني
لانه كما هو معلوم الفيروسات تتغير وتتكيف
ولذلك على الجميع ان يعني يبادر ويسبق هذه
الفيروسات بخلق او انتاج تطعيمات تتوافق
مع هذه الطفرات الدينيه وهذا ما نسعى اليك
منظمه الصحه عالميه في التعاون مع مراكز
الابحاث والدول المصنعه او الشركات
المصنعه لهذه التطعيمه لكن لكن لما نتكلم
عن تطعيمات هناك ما يقارب 13 مليار جرعه
تم توزيعها على مختلف الدول العالم للاسف
30% من الشعوب لم تحصل في مختلف دول
العالم لم تحصل على جرعه واحده وهناك نوعا
ما كما ذكرت سابقا تراقي في وتيره التطعيم
فلذلك علينا ان نعود الى استخدام هذه
التطعيمات والتي ما زالت يعني فاعله في
التعامل مع هذا المرض غير ذلك لا نضمن
فعاليه هذه اللقاحات الا قدر الله ظهرت
قطرات اخرى تتجاوز هذه التطعيمات والمناعه
التي تنتجها لدى الجسم دكتور احمد المنظري
المدير الاقليمي لمنظمه الصحه العالميه
للشرق المتوسط حدثنا من القاهره شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه المعلومات